[Music]
sainsbury why you gotta kick me out it's
just like when I went out with pearl and
her uh producer I was politely asked to
leave the grocery store which has never
happened to me before so I need to take
a look at the company that I keep
security guards are so annoying but
they'll irritate me
when they're just Karen's for no reason
like it's good like it's gonna really
affect your life if I video myself in
Sainsbury's what is the difference
between my man blessing my man blessing
holding a camera versus me holding my
phone and recording you wouldn't even
know do you know how many people film
low quality videos and Sainsbury's all
the time if anything I would like to
speak to the president of Sainsbury's
corporate I would understand if I was
like putting it in people's faces but
let me Vlog in peace